renforcer l'implication des communes
pour accueillir des personnes condamnées
à des travaux d'intérêt général c'est
l'objet des échanges entre des mers
yvelinois eric dupond moretti le garde
des sceaux et amélie de mouchin à la
ministre en charge de la transformation
et de la fonction publique
une rencontre qui s'est tenue au théâtre
de poissy le lundi 30 août présent lors
de cet événement grégory gressier le
maire de maurepas qui souhaite
développer les travaux d'intérêt général
dans sa commune écoutez le on en train
de travailler sur une convention sur un
partenariat justement avec le ministère
de la justice avec l'ouverture de deux
trois postes pour commencer à accueillir
aussi 6 à 7 personnes par an donc on va
commencer par là dans des services
municipaux donc voilà on va dont mettre
en place la recherche de twitter
l'information alors que sont les travaux
d'intérêt général et bien c'est une
sanction pénale institué par la loi du
10 juin 1983 une alternative à
l'incarcération c'est un travail non
rémunéré au profit de la société
l'activité peut être effectuée pour le
compte d'une association de l'état des
collectivités territoriales ou encore
d'un établissement privé en charge de
l'exercice d'une mission de service
public
cette peine concernent des individus
âgés de plus de 16 ans la durée est
déterminée par le juge lors de la
condamnation et ne peut excéder 400
heures pour amplifier le nombre de
partenaires le ministère a lancé en 2019
la plateforme telligent et 360° objectif
répertorier les postes en travaux
d'intérêt général en les cartographiant
un outil accessible pour les partenaires
pour proposer des activités et aux
acteurs judiciaires pour orienter des
condamnés vers leurs tiges le but du jeu
c'est évidemment de mettre en relation
l'ensemble des acteurs du tiges qui ont
besoin de se parler d'avoir le même
niveau d'information et d'avoir les
démarches les plus simplifié possible un
tiges qui va être exécuté à les cinq
mois ou six mois après le délit ça ça
commence à avoir du sens c'est l'idée de
cette plateforme de 360 degrés c'est
l'idée du dispositif ville tiges heures
les villes vont être force de
proposition pour accueillir des travaux
d'intérêt d'intérêt général est
actuellement en date du 31 août 2 21 25
1870 activités sont répertoriées sur la
plateforme tiges
360° dont 177 dans le département des
yvelines